this morning we're launching a new
series it's called the price you pay and
it looks at who's getting rich in this
country while so many Americans fall
behind and we're starting with the price
of college a cost that's supposed to be
an investment by 2020 an estimated 65
percent of jobs are expected to require
at least some college training but that
training has never been more expensive
with the average cost of attending a
public college up tenfold since 1965 we
wanted to find out why
there was a time when college was a
pretty bare-bones experience but these
days Wow there it is
lifeguards and everything students at
Louisiana State University can now enjoy
a 500-foot lazy river that spells out
LSU
hey lifeguard are you a student here too
so you're paying for this you're paying
for the lazy river
lavish perks are now common at major
colleges part of a national arms race
and amenities from fancier dorms to
gourmet food to rec centers that
resemble water parks economists tell us
it's all evidence of a broken system as
states have cut funding for higher
education few universities have cut
their ambition instead they're competing
to expand enrollment and recruit more
out-of-state and international students
who typically pay much more for the same
education and as a result at big state
universities all over the country you
can get harder and harder to actually
find students who are from the state
including here at Penn State sorry to
bother you I got a quick question raise
your hand if you're from Pennsylvania
one guy what are you from California
where you guys from
China Long Island Houston Texas I'm from
Los Angeles I'm an international student
really from Rome so what our College is
doing with all your extra money some of
it goes to teaching of course but most
does not at LSU while students enjoy the
new lazy river some of the academic
facilities are showing their age so the
the library is the focal point of the
quad but would you say it's the focal
point of school funding absolutely not
and I think in anything it's kind of
been neglected by school funding LSU
senior Katherine McKinney took us on a
tour of what she says are her school's
questionable priorities at the library
we saw some of the building literally
falling apart the tuition and fees have
doubled in a decade correct
the library has water in the basement
and rugs from another generation right
but you have a lazy river well we have a
lazy river so maybe I should just get
relaxed
Louisiana State and Penn State declined
our request for an interview but the
president of another major public
university did agree to talk about why
College has become so expensive
what makes this topics are difficult
because there are no good answers and no
good solutions right now Renu Couture is
the president and Chancellor of the
University of Houston where tuition and
fees are more than five times higher
than they were just a couple decades ago
she's also one of the highest-paid
university presidents in the country a
group whose salaries have grown along
with the cost of attendance why couldn't
you leave the classrooms a little bit
old and keep the services a little bit
scaled back and just keep tuition and
fees and room and board down
well I'm glad you have you earn the
university president because you want to
come to a facility you want to come to a
place which feels cared for great as
long as university presidents continue
to be as ambitious as you have been
students around the country and here are
going to walk out with a degree in an
experience but a boatload of debt a
record amount so how does that cycle
break doesn't it break by someone like
yourself saying no more I'm not gonna do
it you are telling me don't be ambitious
for the sake of your students don't be
ambitious about them graduating don't be
ambitious about them learning why am i
university president them I am dead
focused on student success we look at
holistically what students need and what
more we can do for them because at the
end of the day we need more graduates
more college graduates and Chancellor
Couture was courageous enough to sit
down with us a longer interview with her
is going to be on our website and we
want to underscore that this is not an
issue that is unique to LSU or Penn
State or the University of Houston for
that matter LSU by the way claims that
every project on campus including the
lazy river which they call a leisure
river supports the educational
environment and all the schools we spoke
with blame state funding cuts for
causing higher tuition and fees and they
argued they're no more expensive than
their peers but that is true but also
part of the problem it's the competition
between these schools for the full
tuition paying students that's leading
to these fancier amenities focus on
reputation enrollment and prestige not
affordability
I appreciate the university presidents
sitting down with you and speaking so
candidly yeah I mean if you've paid
three college tuitions and in our family
we have right yeah you want
affordability and and there is very
little attention at the schools being
given to know very little and her salary
she's done wonderful things for the
university at the same time none of her
salary is tied to affordability yeah
until that changes college presidents
and College Board's are gonna ramp up
cost and parents are gonna pay the bill
that said to it's also hard guys looking
at a gorgeous lazy river as pretty as it
is and then go to the library and see
that that looks kind of a mess you know
where you spend most of your time by the
way